[Music]
on january 6 2021 trump supporters
attacked the u.s capitol and about a
year ago those insurrectionists started
facing consequences for their actions
and that moved tarik and i so much that
we sang a song about it on this show
that song is our mother jam
that's right
and the charges haven't stopped in fact
the january 6 hearings started last week
and now even more people are shaking in
their boots
yeah
those hearings have me all like
oh baby
you got me all in my feelings [ __ ] is
getting real people are facing jail time
i'm watching these hearings like
oh indeed and whenever i see white
supremacists facing consequences for
their actions well
it fills me up with feelings were word
oh now i know what's wrong but you're
suffering
it brings me joy
is it the way
you looked when the judge said
that you were guilty is it the way
you sweat when you realize they have
your texts is it the way
you smiled when you took a selfie at the
capitol building and is it the way
you frowned when they got that picture
got you thrown in jail i waited for
years well i changed how i'm starting to
shift i feel so ashamed but i must admit
that there's an appeal
to how you make me feel
your sadness fills me with joy i'm
literally filled with joy i'm over the
moon shining with all the stars
[Music]
[Applause]
but mostly so much joy
now what we should do is end the song
here and not double down on the fact
that someone else is suffering makes us
happy you're right
we should stop
yeah we should
and we definitely shouldn't get someone
else involved you're right
ladies and gentlemen elder barge
[Applause]
[Music]
is it the way
your friends and family are on your side
[Music]
[Music]
your sadness
[Music]
[Music]
call me crazy baby that's just how i
feel
[Applause]
you